with the exclusive news on the Sidetrack
channel that Stargate is going to be
returning with a movie I've started to
either think about what that movie might
look like and I think I have the perfect
idea for Amazon
welcome to psycheck your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so we've talked about how there is a
massive risk for Amazon and MGM with
going with this movie first plan now
I've told you guys they intend to kick
off an entire franchise that will have
TV series comic books games and
potentially a few movies
but they have decided to kick off with a
cinematic release of a Stargate film
but
that's a huge risk because if it fails
it could kill the new franchise before
it even starts
so they have to be really really clever
on how they go about this
one way they could do that
is by bringing back Jason Momoa
[Applause]
[Music]
Jason momoa's Galactic career really
kicked off with Stargate Atlantis he
played the character Ronan Dex it could
be my sidekick side chick I'm gonna be
like Batman and Ronan have a nice one to
it yeah
and he was a very popular character even
back then I knew that this guy was going
to be massive obviously he's a big guy
he's a muscular guy and he's he's got
bigger but he has that cheeky little
smile and he is a good actor and he's a
likable actor and he has all the
attributes to be not just a big action
movie star which he's shown but also
when he's doing films like Slumberland
where he has a comic role and again he
was brilliant oh you care to put that to
a test
do you no no not really
so Jason Momoa a big star at the moment
also one of the things I absolutely
adore about Jason Moore is have you ever
seen a lot of the fan pictures he does
where he's hugging a guy's wife and he's
pushing the husband away he actually
does that quite a lot it's just a cheeky
thing he's done been doing for years
really at Comic Cons and things
he just is a likable person not just a
likable actor and he is one of the top
a-listers in Hollywood right now
so if MGM and Amazon could get on the
phone to him and say you know what how
do you fancy coming back for one movie
Stargate Atlantis related film the film
will be based around your character
Roland X maybe he's a runner again for
some reason or just he's got himself
into trouble here on Earth for example
but why would you bring him back and why
would you basically pay his enormous fee
well there's a couple of reasons why it
would be not just a clever idea but a
very easy idea for Amazon and MGM for
one you could do a movie that would
appeal to the widest possible audience
you're going to get people going to this
film that just want to go and see a good
Jason Momoa film they won't even know
they're going to see a Stargate film
now that is really really important if
you then want to kick off a new
franchise because you need as many
people to watch this film as humanly
possible
so an easy way of doing that get a big
star to appear
foreign
that Jason Momoa played Ronan you could
really do lots of things with him he had
a checkered past before we saw him on
Atlantis he was a runner from The Wraith
he had lots and lots of things he had
lots of skills you know I love those
pistols he had it's just amazing this is
a P90 it's a compact lightweight
incredibly sturdy
hey
that's good
all right uh this is a nine millimeter
semi-automatic
it's good too up for this
I can see why he would
and you could see that he would go back
out into the Galaxy and very easily get
himself into trouble now that trouble
could be something that then leads into
the series so he finds out something's
going on maybe maybe The Wraith have got
some secret plan to attack the Earth and
he goes out and he foils the initial
plot but then the plot of The Wraith to
attack the Earth is still there that
could very easily lead into a series now
I'm not saying that Jason Momoa would
then appear in that series he could if
he wanted to
um they'd have to he'd have to take a
lot less money but he could if he wanted
to it would be very easy to create a
movie
that non-stargate fans could happily sit
and watch the Gators would also go crazy
over you could drop enough Easter eggs
in to make it interesting and fun for us
as fans as well as the non-fans
and you could very very easily set up a
problem scenario that feeds into the new
series
it is really a no-brainer why not bring
back Ronan decks and why not do a really
fun popcorn action movie that everyone
can enjoy
and why not use that as a springboard
into the new franchise
lots of television series lots of new
movies
I think it's the easiest the safest and
just one of the most fun ways they can
actually do this
but will they well the rumors I'm
hearing is probably not the most recent
rumor I've heard actually is that Amazon
and MGM do not intend going with any big
a-listers for this project they are very
realistic with their expectations for
how well the movie will do they don't
really care as long as it meets a
certain level of popularity because this
is designed to be a springboard into the
new franchise obviously they're not
going to lose millions and hundreds of
millions of dollars on it but as long as
they kind of break even or make a bit
they're happy because really this is a
massive two-hour advert for the rest of
the franchise
but because of that realistic attitude
they're not going to pay 20 million
dollars for Jason Momoa to return
but there is another option they could
follow
pay him a small fee and give them a bit
of the kick on the end and then if it's
a massively popular movie he makes his
20 million dollars and more given him
executive producer I'll do anything to
get him into this movie
as I say it's unlikely but get into the
comments and tell me what you think is
that a project you would like to see
because God I would pay my ticket
without hesitation
but tell me what you're thinking in the
comments
YouTube Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you will never miss any
of our new videos also don't forget to
go over to our sister Channel sides
where I do a weekly Stargate update if
you're a gator you don't want to miss it
you can also go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our videos
appear first you can watch them there
before everybody else on YouTube and
without the adverts for just a small
monthly fee you also can get like gifts
like a mug and t-shirts and things
depending on what um level you buy so
you know that's always fun too
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]